hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and i can't believe
i get to make this video we just hit
500 000 subscribers
on youtube i never thought this day
would happen and so today's video really
is a thank you to everyone who has
supported the chess website
over the years i started this youtube
channel 12 years ago
i didn't have any fancy equipment i had
a way to record my screen
i know i love chess some crazy chess
openings and i love to
teach and i was very curious would
anyone out there
want to watch my videos i said hey i'm
going to give it a shot so i created
some videos and
every day i would get online just to see
if 10 people
watched my videos not one video all my
videos did 10 total people
watch them and to go from 12 years ago
to see all of the support for the chess
website over the years
has been so exciting to see and so i
just wanted to say
thank you to everyone i never expected
in a million years
that i would get to 500 000 subscribers
my ask in this video is i would love to
thank you each individually if you
wouldn't mind leaving a comment
let me know how long you've been
subscribed to the chess website and also
why do you keep coming back what is it
about the channel
that you really enjoy that when you see
a video you're like i'm excited to
watch that one that's why i subscribe to
the chess website
i would like to see just how everyone
views the channel why they get excited
and also
that's going to give me an opportunity
to thank you i will i will be reading
all of the comments i will be responding
to all the comments
because this this video is really about
you out there who have supported the
chess website over the years so
i can't thank you enough 500 000 is a
crazy number i'm more excited now to
make chess videos than i ever have been
so excited to see
what the future holds for the chess
website but thank you so much for the
support
thanks for watching this video and i
will see you in the next one
take care